ils ont temporairement pris la place des
confiseries et du pop corn
ces produits d'hygiène sont désormais
les nouveaux alliés du directeur du ciné
7 à elancourt autorisée à rouvrir à
partir du 22 juin les salles obscures
sont soumises un protocole strict si le
port du masque est recommandé pour le
public
il faut néanmoins respecter un siège
d'écart entre chaque groupe
on a décidé que avant chaque début de
séance on dirait faire un tour masqués
dans les salles pour vérifier que tout
va bien
voilà et on espère que ce sera bon
enfant et que tout ira bien qu'on n'aura
pas intervenir
l'établissement est lent courtois fait
le choix de ne pas mettre en place de
réservation par internet
la billetterie se fera donc sur place en
respectant une file d'attenté unique et
les distance adéquate
nous avons ici des gens qui sont des
passionnés depuis parfois 30 ou 40 ans
qui sont des abonnés qui sont de
fervents admirateurs mes supporters du
cinéma sont pas des clients sont des
supporters nous ont multiplié les
messages entre autres sur les réseaux
sociaux pour demander qu'on rouvre est
une reprise progressive également pour
le multiplexe ugc ciné cité à skywest
les seize salles rouvriront à partir du
22 juin à 16 heures avec une contrainte
comme partout ailleurs la capacité est
diminuée de moitié
les salles seront également à errer
entre chaque séance les intéressés ans
sont beaucoup plus importante
qu'auparavant donc entre chaque film il
y aura quasiment à minima une demi heure
entre chaque séance pour que les gens
qui sortent ne croise pas forcément les
gens qui rentrent dans la salle
concernant la programmation aucune
grosse sortie n'est prévue pour la
semaine de reprise on a décidé de
relancer les incontournables ugc qui
sont les meilleurs films de l'année 2019
donc ça on va le programmer pendant une
quinzaine de jours à 3 euros 50
l'occasion de voir ou de revoir pendant
les premières semaines de réouverture le
champ du loup hors norme ou encore les
misérables
une séance spéciale est prévue le
dimanche 12 juillet pour découvrir une
nouveauté tout simplement noir en
présence de l'équipe du film